[Music]
we had some absolutely fantastic games
in 2017 in ten shooters grand strategy
groundbreaking new entries into adored
series we were spoiled now it might be
the Jedi in me talking but there must be
balance in all things whether it's good
there must also be bad so for balance
sake for the five worst reviewed games
of 2017 playing Reservoir Dogs bloody
days was probably more uncomfortable
than watching mr. blonde danced around
2k Billie's sound of the 70s while he
cuts off a poor cops ear but at least
that had good music the game shares
almost nothing in common with its
namesake apart from dudes and suits
doing some very naughty deeds there's a
pointing thing is that the potential to
be an exciting twin stick shooter is
there in its rewind system but it's too
marred in repetition and frustration to
really let anything shine and it's a
damn shame you get hit with this damn
like a Reservoir Dam with clone to
deaths biggest role was its visuals it's
wonderfully daft and over-the-top and
thankfully continues to shine during
live gameplay but the draw the game
unfortunately stops there yes those puns
were intended weapons are imbalanced
movement and physics are cumbersome and
it might have one of the worst British
accents in games not that I'm biased
your word food your poxy wake up sniper
ghost Warrior 3 is a long shot away from
being a terrible game but it doesn't
quite hit the mark either it'll go
through great efforts to show you how
cool the sniping is but then force you
into scenarios where you have to use
closed combat weapons or stealth kills
which are parts the game where the
faults really start to show that coupled
with some crazy loading times it seems
that the game just doesn't have the
range for a brief moment it looked like
the sonic franchise was saved we had a
truly good Sonic game the title that was
in every fans lips was sonic mania for a
few months and then sonic forces came
out the lovers and sonic forces simply
don't work at the time and when they do
work they're robbed of their speed and
spectacle sure you can make your own
Hedgehog or rabbit or bear or whatever
honestly it's more fun to just google
your name and add the hedgehog at the
end than it is to wrestle with boring
disappointing sonic forces
Niva speed payback is the second game in
this list which suffers with speed the
Need for Speed franchise has always been
a series of games that has allowed you
to keep the accelerator firmly pushed
into the floor to be even at top speeds
it never feels like you're going fast in
payback then there's also the tedious
push to grind for cards and repeat
events in order to upgrade your vehicles
there are parts the nevis beef franchise
that are truly great I just don't know
where they've put them instead we have a
mediocre racer that tries to capture the
feeling of fast and furious but
unfortunately runs flat so those were
some of the worst reviewed games on
GameSpot calm this year let us know in
the comments what your dud moments in
gaming were in 2017 but above all else
remember that this is just a bit of fun
and at the end of the day we're all just
big nerdy video game fans so be rad to
eachother and Happy Holidays
you